[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi 20
octobre une centaine de personnes
réunies devant la préfecture de
versailles pour réclamer plus
d'hébergement d'urgence l'appel et
élancées par de nombreuses associations
du territoire qu après une série
d'expulsions ces dernières semaines mari
et ma boursiers notre invité fil rouge
pour cette émission doyen de la faculté
de droit et de sciences politiques de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous
évoquerons avec elle la rentrée
solennelle de la faculté et les
révélations qui ne cesse d'éclore sur
les affaires de harcèlement sexuel en
france et ailleurs
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
locale retour sur la fronde des
départements franciliens à propos de
l'avenir de la métropole du grand paris
ou encore l'élection de jean luc hugo à
la mairie de montigny le bretonneux
lui aussi vient d'être élu c'était jeudi
soir jean michel fourgous est devenu
sans surprise le nouveau président de
saint quentin en yvelines il remplace
michel laugier touché par la loi sur le
non cumul des mandats après son élection
au sénat jean michel fourgous a
rassemblé 38 voix sur 75 possibles
contre 20 pour son seul adversaire le
socialiste bertrand ou lyon le maire
d'elancourt a notamment exprimé toute sa
fierté au micro de tv 78e les coudes
c'est une élection d'un d'un d'un
symbole important france la numération
de saint-quentin monte quand même en
gamme avec la qualité et des entreprises
et laboratoires des universités des
chercheurs et des événements
aujourd'hui les connotations mondiale
que vous connaissez donc il s'agit de
rassembler après tout après tout le
monde autour de ses grands projets je
pense que cette agglomération a beaucoup
de chance et je salue mes prédécesseurs
c'est pas moi qui ai fait tout cela et
moi maintenant d'apporter une valeur
ajoutée ainsi vous faire élire président
mais il faut être capable d'apporter une
valeur ajoutée à l'ensemble de ces deux
qualités de ses projets de ses
savoir-faire et sachez que ce soir ce
vendredi soir la rédaction de tv soit
118 vous propose un set 8 politiques
spéciales pour revenir sur cette
élection à partir de 20 heures avec
notamment la première vice-présidente de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines joséphine
coleman ce berger et donc jean-michel
fourgous le nouveau président de
l'agglomération organisations syndicales
associations de droit au logement
famille ou encore militants ils étaient
tous se rassembler devant la préfecture
de versailles c'était jeudi soir ils
réclament ils réclament plus de places
d'hébergement d'urgence alors que 70
familles dorment actuellement dans la
rue dans les yvelines elle les
précisions avec ce reportage
sous les fenêtres de la préfecture de
versailles le message est repris en
choeur par une centaine de personnes à
l'appel de nombreuses associations et
mouvements locaux les manifestants
étaient réunis pour réclamer plus de
places d'hébergement d'urgence
actuellement 70 familles dorment dans la
rue dans les yvelines et à palinges où
il n'ya pas ya pas qu'à laval et aucun
pour 6 buts et pour dormir et les
enfants semblaient s'en aller l'alcool
froch
comme tout le monde ils sont besoin de
lui comme tout le monde c'est
insupportable à notre époque
voilà or il y aurait certainement moyen
d'augmenter le
de logements d'accueil et surtout d
accueil pérenne lancé à l'initiative
d'une trentaine de mouvements yvelinois
l'eau rassemblement fait suite à
l'évacuation ces dernières semaines de
plusieurs campements sur le département
comme à saint quentin en yvelines début
octobre pour tenter de trouver une
solution le préfet des yvelines a reçu
pendant plus d'une heure une délégation
de huit personnes
on n'attendait pas forcément non plus de
l'état tout de suite qu'ils ont trouvé
des places d'hébergement
je crois qu'il a il nous a montré qu'il
avait du souci de de l'hébergement ce
qui nous interpelle plus celle à
l'incohérence de ce démantèlement de
bidonvilles qui pour certains ne sont
pas dans un état d'insalubrité tels que
on met les gens à la rue après les avoir
hébergé pendant quinze jours à l'hôtel
pour cet hiver la préfecture a annoncé
l'ouverture supplémentaire de 240 places
d'hébergement un plan global sera
également présentée l'an prochain
toujours dans l'actualité ce jeudi la
faculté de droit de l'ue vers ce qu
organiser sa rentrée solennelle en
présence notamment de l'ancien garde des
sceaux
jean jacques urvoas et en présence aussi
de mari et ma boursiers qui étaient avec
nous en plateau bonsoir marié ma
boursier vous êtes doyen de la faculté
de droit de sciences politiques de l'ue
vs qc le nom complet depuis le mois de
juillet juin dernier précisément dit
nous en quoi consiste on a vu quelques
images en quoi consiste une rentrée
solennelle je crois savoir que le nom
est un peu trompeur
alors il est trompeur par rapport à la
date de rentrée nos étudiants qui sont
rentrés le 11 septembre cette année mais
nous sommes quand même pas si éloigné de
cette rentrée physique des étudiants qui
ont repris leur cours il s'agit pour
nous d'honorer nos meilleurs étudiants
de l'année précédente nommage horde
année de licence et de master 2 et puis
de retrouver et de rassembler l'ensemble
de notre communauté universitaire donc
enseignants-chercheurs étudiants équipe
administrative en présence d'invités de
représentants de la vie locale et du
coup de lancer aussi on va dire
officiellement entamé la nouvelle année
ça pourrait être ça aurait pu être un
terme cérémonie mais rentrée est aussi
la rentrée universitaire évidemment
alors globalement comment ce comment se
présente 7,7 cette année universitaire
ça fait un mois que vous avez repris des
problèmes particuliers à signaler ou
alors j'ai envie de dire tout va bien
tout va bien à peu près sa rentrée s'est
bien passée
notre principale préoccupation est
d'accueillir les étudiants dans de
bonnes conditions pédagogiques
évidemment et administratives
ce qui est le cas globalement ça s'est
bien passé
oh je le disais vous êtes-vous doyen de
la faculté de droit de sciences
politiques expliquez-nous un petit peu
qu est-ce qu en quoi ça consiste être
doyen c'est un titre un nom que l'on
connaît mais on ne sait pas forcément à
quoi à quoi ça sert concrètement ce qui
est légitime c'est une fonction à une
fonction de doyen on est on dirige une
unité une composante qui s'est créé
qu'une faculté en l'occurrence et on
sert d'animateur et de l'équipe
d'enseignants chercheurs en se projetant
sur les projets pédagogiques mais aussi
sur la recherche qui fait le coeur aussi
de notre métier à côté de l'enseignement
et puis sur l'accompagnement des
étudiants pédagogique avec toutes les
volets administratifs que l'on peut
imaginer
alors ce que je vais dire va peut-être
paraître logique qui est un peu cliché
mais vous n'êtes pas un homme
vous n'êtes pas à j'ai clairement c'est
une fausse idée de penser que
généralement les doyens de facultés sont
sondés homme d'un certain âge ou alors
vous êtes vraiment une exception dans
dans le milieu non je n'ai pas une
exception d'un certain âge oui c'est une
fausse idée c'était peut-être le cas il
ya quelques années mais ce n'est plus le
cas à mon sens une exception quant à
auffay que je sois une femme non mais il
est certain que pour l'heure il ya moins
de fans doyen que d'hommes de temps les
facultés de droit
donc c'est quelque chose qui a tendance
à évoluer qui restaient ils travaillent
sur ces questions à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
nous avons une charge et qui est de deux
missions qui travaillent sur ces
questions de parité mais c'est
évidemment une question nationale et oui
ça évoluera certainement
alors évidemment je vous pose cette
question non sans lien avec l'actualité
de ces derniers
pour toutes ces révélations d'agression
douar sainement sexuelle qui concernent
des femmes ça a commencé par le cinéma
depuis on se rend compte malheureusement
que ça touche tous les domaines tous les
secteurs sont touchés alors première
question est ce que le monde de
l'enseignement supérieur est lui aussi
concerné par ce type d'événements
malheureux certainement le monde dans
l'enseignement supérieur être le reflet
d'une part de ce qu'est la société donc
il l'est certainement après je pense ni
plus statistiquement nous
personnellement vous avez jamais été
sujets à ce type de comportement ou où
on ne vous a jamais raconté ce type de
comportement sur sur des rien de rien de
rien mais rien de remarquable mais voilà
il n'y a aucune raison qu'on ne soit pas
l'image de ceux de ce que peut être
celle de la société puis alors permettez
moi d'insister mais vous êtes brillant
depuis la fin juin ça fait quelques
semaines que vous êtes dans votre votre
rôle désormais de doyen est ce que vous
avez eu aussi peut-être des remarques un
peu désobligeantes sur le fait que vous
soyez une femme encore une fois pas très
âgée ce que vous avez vu ce type de
remarque
merci pour le pas très âgées je faisais
moi seul c'était malheureusement pendant
que d'autres et c'est une plaisanterie
non je n'ai pas eu de remarque meyer si
ç'avait été le cas ça aurait été faite
de façon feutrée certainement mais c'est
pas ce n'est pas le cas vous êtes une
femme de droit évidemment je voudrais
vous faire réagir sur sur un chiffre
parmi beaucoup que l'on peut voir
paraître en ce moment dans dans la
presse dans l'actualité celui ci est
parue dans le parisien du globe journal
le parisien de mardi dernier
93% des plaintes pour harcèlement sexuel
sont classées sans suite en france
notamment faute de preuves
c'est un chiffre qui peut comme ça en
tout cas paraître hallucinant pour
quelqu'un qui n'a pas qui n'est pas
habituée aux affaires de droit est ce
que l'on peut dire aujourd'hui un peu de
façon inquiétante que la justice
française protège mal les femmes
victimes de harcèlement sexuel ou alors
c'est exagéré je pense que dans l'absolu
les femmes victimes de harcèlement ou de
violence sont mal protégés parce que les
dispositifs légaux sont très difficiles
à mettre en place et qu'ils doivent être
accompagnés dispositifs sociaux inde
aide financière logistique pour les
femmes qui souffrent de ce type de
l'agression sur le harcèlement sexuel
vous l'avez dit
vous même il ya une question de preuves
qui est très lourde à apporter et même
si législateur a précisé en 2012 en
réécrire le texte sur le harcèlement
sexuel il ya vraiment une problématique
de perception de collecte de la preuve
de démonstration et puis de témoignages
qui sont généralement très difficile
si je comprends bien aujourd'hui c'est
plus le cadre qui est défaillant sa
définition du harcèlement
même si elle a été précisé mais pas
encore assez
on risque bien d'être aussi c'est en
fait c'est ça la le problème est là
c'est à dire qu'il ya autant de
comportements qu'il peut y avoir de
d'hypothèses de comportement que de
preuves potentielles donc c'est très
difficile d'aller plus loin dans la
législation
les vraies questions là juridique dans
laquelle nous nous entrerons pas sans
celle de la répétition par exemple
est-ce qu'il faut une répétition ou non
quel type de comportement doit être
direct ou peut-il être indirecte
bon tout ça il ya un aspect juridique
mais globalement c'est un problème
vraiment de démonstration ensuite alors
vous évoquiez la loi de 2012 qui prévoit
actuellement deux ans d'emprisonnement
pour harcèlement sexuel et 30000 euros
damende c'est le double de la loi
précédente
est-ce que aussi le principal finalement
c'est une réflexion est ce que le
principal ce n'est pas le volet
prévention prévention que ce soit dans
le monde de l'entreprise
que ce soit auprès des plus jeunes à
l'université ou encore peut-être encore
plus jeunes on va peut-être pas parler
de harcèlement sexuel à des enfants qui
ont aussi sous sept ans mais d'égalité
homme femme
c'est ce que c'est là le volet le plus
principal le plus important les deux
doivent être conjuguées c'est à dire
qu'il ya un travail de fond sur le
comportement en société
et là toutes les réflexions les actions
menées sur l'égalité hommes femmes sur
la perception de cette égalité sont
fondamentales pour faire changer les
mentalités
après la sanction pénale la menace de
sanctions pénales ce caractère préventif
qui dit mais attention si vous adoptez
ce comportement vous risquez deux ans
d'emprisonnement ce qui évidemment n'est
pas neutre à son utilité et le droit
pénal est là aussi pour dire aux
citoyens que nous sommes qu'il y a des
comportements que la loi pénale ne
tolérera pas et ces comportements
d'atteintes sexuelles aux femmes sont
introduits dans le code pénal depuis peu
de temps ce qui veut dire que
société a réagi assez tardivement pour
toujours avec ce type d'affaires oui un
projet de loi contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes doit voir le jour
au premier semestre 2018 c'est
l'actualité on l'a appris cette semaine
on connaît les contours sans connaître
les précisions de ce projet de loi
notamment un allongement du délai de
prescription des délits sexuels ce n'est
pas arrêté mais en tout cas c'est une
piste largement évoqué ce que vous y est
favorable actuellement ses vingt ans
après la majorité ce qu'il faut
augmenter cette période là je suis
partagé je pense que le droit beaucoup
évolué et lorsqu'il a justement fait
courir le délai de prescription à la
majorité de la victime puisqu'il est
évident que si vous êtes victime de
violences sexuelles à 12 ans vous n'êtes
pas en mesure 2 après il ya vraiment la
question du dépérissement des preuves si
vous allongez à 30 ont trente ans après
les faits enfin ça devient très très
compliqué de collecter des preuves
je pense qu'un droit de bien accompagner
tellement extrait finalement de porter
cette cette durée à 30 ans mais reste
qu'il va vous répondre ça coûte c'est
que si on décide de changer la loi qui
doit quand même en elle même a priori
avoir une certaine pérennité il faut qu'
on en attend d'une certaine efficacité
et si elle n'est pas là c'est pas
forcément utile est-ce que excusez moi
une question un peu naïve mais est-ce
que des témoignages ont valeur de preuve
endroits notamment dans ce type
d'affaires on parle de preuves notamment
j'imagine physique pour harcèlement pour
l'agression est ce que des témoignages
ont valeur de preuve et bien sûr des
preuves testimoniales donc le témoin à
l'audience va déposer ensuite la
conviction de la juridiction se fera en
fonction des témoignages et selon
l'intimé conviction des jurés en assises
ou des juges puis l'autre axe majeur de
ce projet de loi qui se dessine et qu'il
a va faire sûrement débat de façon très
très très importante très marquée c'est
la pénalisation du harcèlement de rue
beaucoup de questions se posent sur la
définition de ce harcèlement doré c'est
toujours la même problématique sur
l'atteinte aussi supposé ou liberté des
individus
est-ce que selon vous c'est possible de
définir précisément ce qu'est le
harcèlement de rue est ce que c est une
une chose est notamment ceux qui
évoquent une atteinte à la liberté ce
que est ce que c'est un argument valable
pour le contre pour le compte il ya
d'autres arguments peut-être plus
valable que celui là la question de la
preuve la va se retrouver aussi de façon
très importante et de la définition vous
posiez est-ce qu'on est dans une liste
est-elle limitative ou pas est-ce que
siffler une femme dans la rue la
regarder d'une façon désagréable comptes
constitue constitue cette cette violence
bon de se passer des wagons qui sont un
peu moi cette politesse quotidien qui
seraient potentiellement dévolu en
partie pour ses missions
c'est toujours par ailleurs pour
apprécier les comportements environ la
question de la preuve est crucial or
après des paroles c'est autre chose mais
on a déjà un dispositif juridique qui
pourrait de l'injure par exemple enfin
dans d'autres cadres qui pourrait être
inspirant mais c'est quand même c'est
quand même très compliqué peut-être
qu'il y aura une vertu un peu
prophylactique de dire que l'espace
public ne doit pas donner lieu à ce type
de comportement que la société le
condamne
dernière question sur le sujet je
m'adresse à la spécialiste du droit puis
aussi à la femme est ce que selon vous
on al'opportunité cette fois-ci vraiment
de changer les choses que ce soit pour
les femmes victimes de parler et pour
les hommes agresseurs de changer leur
comportement est ce que là on a une
fenêtre de tir selon l'expression un peu
unique
oui mais il faut qu'il y en ait beaucoup
et que ça se prolongera dans le temps
voilà ça ne changera pas les choses même
si cette loi voit le jour je crois que
c'est une prise de conscience
généralisée qui font un travail de fou
une dernière question on change
complètement de sujets est ce que vous
êtes favorable à la mise en place de
prérequis pour l'entrée à l'université
c'était aussi un sujet d'actualité pour
la rentrée prochaine est ce que c'est
une bonne chose pour éviter et tirage au
sort qui sont qui sont nos mauvais selon
l'avis de tous
oui je crois vraiment le travail qui est
engagé sur ces prérequis comme sur
d'autres réformes c'est d'essayer de
traiter la problématique des étudiants
qui arrivent en masse
sans orientation en fonction d'un profil
de leur profil à l'université et on le
voit chez nous comme ailleurs et qui
finalement ne sont pas faits pour le
domaine qu'ils ont choisi coût de cet
endroit en situation d'échec et ce qui
est difficile à vivre pour un jeune de
18 19 ans qui redouble qui ne réussit
pas qui bon donc je pense que essayé
d'orienter activement les étudiants et
futurs étudiants pour les amener vers ce
qui pourrait leur corresponde le mieux
en compétences je crois que c'est une
bonne chose que là aussi sur le problème
des prérequis il faut il faut bien
définir la chose qu'est ce qu'on
considère comme à ercis comment après
retire tous tes problèmes de définition
apparemment donc on discute dans toutes
nos instances que soit la conférence des
doyens la conférence des présidents
d'université évidemment ministère dans
les groupes de travail
nous sommes à l'oeuvre merci marie emma
boursiers d'être venu sur notre plateau
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes doyen de la
faculté de droit de sciences politiques
de l'ue vs q merci à vous on passe tout
de suite à l'actualité de la semaine
cette semaine marque qui une nouvelle
fois par la grogne des présidents des
départements de la grande couronne il
organisait mardi une réunion publique à
propos de l'avenir de la métropole du
grand paris c'était à versailles devant
un parterre de 800 personnes les élus
ont rappelé leur volonté de voir le
périmètre de la métropole élargi aux
frontières de la région et ce à quelques
jours des annonces prévues sur le sujet
par le gouvernement la rédaction de tv
78 a interrogé pierre bédier pour les
yvelines et patrick devedjian pour les
hauts-de-seine à l'issue de cette
réunion publique il détaillait leur
motivation extraits peu importe que les
informations soient bonnes ou mauvaises
nous sommes optimistes par nature et on
se bat pas ce que c'est pour nous une
telle évidence qu'on ne peut pas séparer
la grande couronne de la petite couronne
pourquoi ne pas aussi est installé comme
on le faisait entre l'allemagne de l'est
et l'allemagne de l'ouest des
checkpoints donc pour passer à vélizy
mais ça c'est là pour passer dans les
hauts-de-seine
on aurait cinq portes il faudrait
présenter un papier d'identité en fait
tout ça tout ça et groupe s à une époque
on nous parle de mondialisation où on
nous parle de d'élargir nos horizons
en france on veut réduire l'horizon et
construire les murs là où de toute
évidence il faut essayer d'être beaucoup
plus large beaucoup plus rassembleur
beaucoup plus dynamique et surtout
préoccupés par le développement
économique
l lundi ce sont les élus de versailles
et saint quentin en yvelines qui étaient
mobilisés à guyancourt objets de leur
rassemblement l'avenir de la ligne 18 du
grand paris express maires députés ou
sénateurs espèrent l'arrivée de la ligne
dès 2024 et s'inquiète d'un éventuel
abandon du projet de la part du
gouvernement
reportage de nicolas landry et aurélie
rose mobilisés pour interpeller le
gouvernement élus des communes de saint
quentin en yvelines du département de la
région députés et sénateurs se sont
réunis à guyancourt sur le site qui
pourrait devenir la gare de la ligne 18
sur l'agglomération tous présents pour
défendre la mise en oeuvre du projet
ferroviaire avant 2024
aujourd'hui les jeux olympiques c'est un
enjeu aussi fondamentale on ne peut pas
avoir deux discours dire que nous allons
recevoir les jeux olympiques
appuyez s'appuyer là dessus au niveau du
cio à lima et ensuite derrière nous dire
que abane ont finalement n'aura pas
c'est impossible donc pour être rassurés
par le ministère il faut nous recevoir
rapidement et qu'on puisse avec les
entrepreneurs la population annoncer la
bonne nouvelle
cette bonne nouvelle c'est l'arrivée du
tracé de la ligne 18 dans les yvelines
avant les jeux olympiques avec une gare
située à guyancourt communes qui
accueillent 1200 entreprises et de
nombreux salariés au quotidien sa compta
en yvelines c'est le deuxième pôle
économique de l'île de france
on peut pas absolument pas du tout ne
pas avoir de transport structurants et
il faut qu'on se bouge nous
effectivement les élus les habitants les
entreprises et les étudiants pour faire
reconnaître que notre territoire est
incontournable un échelon proche des
politiques nationales certains élus
yvelinois ont des ressources importantes
pour peser sur la décision du calendrier
concernant la ligne 18 nous avons
sollicité le préfet de région pour lui
demander là dessus des clarifications
pour lui demander une étude de
faisabilité sur le calendrier qui
pourrait demander à la société du grand
paris
nous avons un certain nombre d'éléments
naturellement qu'ils nous laissent
penser que boucler ce projet en 2024
jusqu'à versailles de cette ligne 18 est
tout à fait faisable
j'irai rappelé les engagements de l'état
au plus haut niveau et j'essaierai de
rentrer dans des bureaux qui aujourd'hui
ne sont pas encore ouverts je crois que
les ministères chargés de ce dossier
sont au travail qui vont remettre un
moment donné leur copie au premier
ministre et et qu'à ce moment là une
fois que les hypothèses seront sur la
table le dialogue s'enclenchera avec les
élus locaux pour voir quelle est la
solution la plus efficace et la deûle et
celle qui sera de nature à répondre aux
besoins en marche de cette mobilisation
des élus écologistes de l'agglomération
ont tenu à exprimer leur opposition à ce
projet est lundi toujours jean luc
ourgaud est devenu le nouveau maire de
montigny le bretonneux l'ancien adjoint
remplace michel laugier élu en septembre
au sénat y l'a largement emporté durant
ce vote avec 37 voix pour
lors d'un conseil municipal
extraordinaire l'émotion était palpable
ce soir là
reportage
ils ont travaillé plus de vingt ensemble
au sein de cette assemblée
l'un quitte son poste l'autre le
découvre dans un moment très solennel
jean le court go a été élu largement
nouveau maire de montigny le bretonneux
ce lundi 16 octobre à 67 ans avec 30 de
bulletins pour sur 37 le nouvel élu
souhaite se placer dans l'action de son
prédécesseur
moi je m'inscris complètement dans les
pas de michel laugier encore une fois
comment pourrait-il en être différemment
puisque jusqu'à présent tous les
collègues de la liste ont voté pour le
programme qui a été le nôtre
donc oui c'est une continuité et pas du
tout une rupture
devenu sénateur fin septembre michel
auger qui donc un siège qu'il a occupé
pendant 13 ans ce conseil municipal
était aussi l'occasion pour les élus de
lui rendre un dernier hommage faut que
les choses sont faites quel nouveau
maire montigny le bretonneux à la tête
de l'équipe que j'ai eu l'honneur le
plaisir de conduire de sélectionner dont
je leur souhaite beaucoup de succès et
je serai toujours là avec un deck
bienveillant le nouvel organigramme
municipal n'est modifié qu'à la marge
suzanne blanc conserve ainsi son poste
de première adjointe en charge de la vie
scolaire
yannick le dorze intègre lui l'exécutif
et devient responsable de la
communication une continuité qui ne
devrait pas bouleverser les relations
parfois tendues avec l'opposition
je pense qu'on a intérêt à continuer à
se battre sans relâche pour faire valoir
nos propositions allaient faire entendre
à les faire accepter parfois comme ça
parfois été le cas avec michel laugier
j'espère que ce sera le cas aussi là
avec avec jean-luc ourgaud après on a
quelques désaccords quand même sur
est-ce que montigny aujourd'hui est une
ville exemplaire en matière d'écologie
en matière de solidarité après la mairie
de montigny le bretonneux une nouvelle
élection aura lieu jeudi prochain au
sein du conseil d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour élire le
successeur de michel logis à la
présidence de la collectivité à poste
qui devrait revenir au maire d'elancourt
jean michel fourgous et vous l'aurez
donc compris le poste est revenu à jean
michel fourgous qui est donc devenu lui
le président de saint quentin en
yvelines
les travaux ont débuté depuis le mois de
février sur le pont et l'avenue
fuller entre maurepas et la gare de la
verrière le chantier a pour but de
doubler les voies de la structure avec
la création d'un corridor pour les
transports en commun le point sur les
travaux avec camille lambert et mélanie
poquet l'asphalt vient tout juste d'être
posée côté gare de la verrière la route
réservée au tcsp transport collectif en
site propre est quasiment terminé la
partie asphaltée qu'est la plus
brillante c'est réservé aux piétons
cc non glissant à ce n'est pas parce que
c'est brillant c'est glissant la partie
plus large je vais être séparé en deux
cd voies cyclables pour la et puis la
partie entre les bordures en granit
engrais exactement sera réservé à terme
uniquement au tcsp la déviation actuelle
deviendra pérenne pour les véhicules
particuliers
du côté de maurepas le doublement du
pont schuller a pris du retard
un prolongement d'environ deux mois et
demi de travaux est envisagé lors des
explorations qui ont été faites
initialement avant le début des travaux
au niveau des culées des bombes n'ont
pas peut être décelée sur ces deux
culées de part et d'autre de la
nationale
des pieux qui avait été installé il y à
quelques dizaines d'années en prévision
certainement déjà du doublement de ce
pont et il a fallu donc ré envisager la
une construction différentes et de
prévoir des micropieux un retard et un
surcoût près de 500000 euros de plus
pour cette partie des travaux
le budget initial était de près de 9
millions d'euros dont plus de six
millions de subventions de l'état de la
région et du département
les fans de cyclisme se réjouissent
forcément le prochain tour de france
sera de passage une nouvelle fois dans
les yvelines le tracé de la 105e grande
boucle a été dévoilée mardi le départ de
la dernière étape se fera de houille
cela faisait cinq ans que le département
n'avait pas accueilli le tour de france
c'était alors la ville de
versailles c'est la fin de ce set 8
l'hebdo autour de l'information en
direct lundi à 18 heures d'ici là restez
informés et connecté grâce à notre
application
atv 78 bon week-end à tous et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]